hey this is really just
weird and it kind of epitomizes stuff
we've been talking about for a long time
i guess there was an event at trump's
mar-a-lago
and at the event
there were gay supporters of trump
and i don't want to focus on why there
are gay supporters of trump like
obviously
it doesn't really make a lot of sense
although i don't really think trump is
personally very homophobic or or at all
necessarily but i think he has
chosen to buy in i don't think trump
cares one way or the other trump cares
about gay people as much as he cares
about anybody else
which is he doesn't he just doesn't
really care about people whether they're
gay or straight but he's certainly done
the homophobic transphobic politics
since deciding to run as a republican
republican and getting pulled in to this
reactionary movement so in any case
there are gay trump supporters some of
them were at a fundraiser in florida and
trump said to them you don't look gay
yeah
let's look at the clip
thank you very much
you don't look good
[Laughter]
you know this uh
clearly trump seems to think gay people
have to look a certain way or that they
do i don't know
this reminds me of as many of you if you
only there's people who have no idea
what i look like because they only
listen to my show they don't watch it
uh i am i guess what's considered white
hispanic like i'm from argentina grew up
uh
speaking spanish as my first language
and then learned english and okay you
know so that's that's the deal
and um because i learned english early
enough i don't have an accent except
when i say certain words like nuclear
and people when they learn that i am
hispanic by the definition of the u.s
census sometimes they i can tell they
don't even know they're doing it they
will reflexively go
oh you you don't look hispanic at all
almost like they're saying oh i never
would have guessed you were sick you
don't you don't look sick at all like
it's a compliment that i don't look what
they believe hispanic people look like
and i don't you know this is not like
the gravest injustice i find it funny
the reaction that i sometimes got from
people and it's kind of a similar thing
for example oh you guys are gay oh you
don't look gay
again as if that's a good thing they
don't conform to whatever stereotype of
gayness
trump would have imagined
uh and i guess you know when i say when
i said earlier i don't know that trump
is that homophobic that's a pretty
homophobic idea actually if i do say so
myself
but very strange times at trump's
fundraisers and i expect these to get
wackier and wackier as the 2022 election
comes forward because trump is he seems
to be making an effort
to actually support the candidacies of
different people
and in order to do that
you start to be around a lot of
different people and
trump doesn't seem to know how to relate
to a lot of different types of people
which is which is a weird thing but
apparently
the gay trump supporters were not
offended
they found it funny so that's that
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want from the
foods i'm eating but that's why athletic
greens ag-1 is so great it's a solution
that gives you everything in one scoop
and you get 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals as well as probiotics so it
supports gut health it is one of the
great sort of add-ons to having proper
balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
the link is down below